ha aprobado con 38 con 38 votos
afirmativos y 29 negativos y una
abstención con el anuncio de la decisión
de la cámara alta las calles de buenos
aires estallaron en el júbilo de la
llamada marea verde un día histórico así
lo definieron las mujeres a favor del
proyecto que vivieron tensos momentos a
las afueras de la sede legislativa
esperando el resultado de la votación
tras 12 horas de debate muy emocional
histórico
es historia no hay más que decir nuevos
colores
[Música]
[Aplausos]
empieza el margen de votos menos
estrecho de lo esperado dio finalmente
luz verde a un derecho que las
argentinas llevan reivindicando desde
hace mucho en 2018 una ley similar se
aprobó en la cámara de diputados pero se
están con el senado un año después el
presidente alberto fernández prometió
impulsar el aborto el legal y gratuito
durante su campaña electoral por lo que
su aprobación representa un éxito para
el peronista tras un difícil 2020 el
aborto seguro legal y gratuito es ley a
ello me comprometí en los días de
campaña electoral hoy somos una sociedad
mejor que amplía derechos a las mujeres
y garantiza la salud pública recuperar
el valor de la palabra empeñada
compromiso de la política pero no todos
celebraron los llamados pro-vida
identificados por su color celeste
también se reunieron a las afueras del
congreso y condenaron la decisión de
legalizar la interrupción del embarazo a
pesar de la fuerte influencia de la
iglesia católica en el país a partir de
ahora en la
o legal y gratuito hasta la semana 14 de
gestación será ley más allá las mujeres
podrán abortar en los casos
anteriormente permitidos por violación o
peligro para la vida de la madre